and uh i think another thing that i'm
really i'm so sorry to touch you
there's one rule here yeah
let me just get that yeah
[Music]
what's happening there reject nation
greg and john
we're gonna watch superman and lois
episode three today guys if you haven't
done so already please
smash that like button and subscribe and
click that notification about to get
notified when our next video is up this
is youtube
so can't show the whole thing obviously
this is reaction highlights full length
reaction watch along where you can sync
up with the timecode with this is over
at our patreon page
and over there we cover so many damn tv
shows we're at the same tier
you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch along
included from my understanding people
have been enjoying it which makes me
feel good and it'll make you feel good
too little massage in the heart lastly
gotta thank our friend pratham jindal
for editing the reaction highlights
portion of this video for us thought you
did a great job last time i think he'll
do an even better job
today check out his youtube channel link
in the pinned comments and description
box anywho let's get into this people
done does this have too much blue in it
mom can we just pick something
sweetie this is an important decision
we're finally putting our own stamp on
this house
we need the right shade of taupe you
like this color yeah
fine yeah yeah
laser belt blast his head off
oh someone starts shaking people
[Music]
oh oh he just wants to hang out with his
family huh you gotta at least start
getting good at being like
i'll be back
all the way in china wow
gotta peel that chinese market i knew
his hearing was good you know
second or you could just be in the
middle of a dinner
oh
are you okay chinese person you can hear
every sound in the world at once it's
more like i hear all the fluctuations
taking place in the collective sonic
frequency
what's the most embarrassing thing
you've ever heard nope not appropriate
to be honest was there nudity involved
maybe when you guys are older oh come on
come on
there's the story there clark that's the
superman show i want to see
every power comes with its own burden
some responsibilities
like with great power comes great
it's important that we don't draw
unnecessary attention to our family
if anyone ever found out the truth about
me it would change everything it's not
like we're worried about it is someone
gonna find out the truth about him in
this episode
i don't know man as it's possible what
if somebody we know came in
they might ask questions you know if
this is something you're so embarrassed
about then maybe we shouldn't be doing
it anymore
why does it feel like i'm the only one
that's still worried about this
stop with this are they trying to get
pregnant
hey baby hey honey here's a new baby oh
they take her to therapy
how did it go with dr lawrence that's
between me and her
i'm seeing dr lawrence like you asked
okay did you say anything about morgan
ed
i've been meaning to ask you this after
school could we
possibly hang out
i've been waiting here all day
no cigar pal nice try
find some nudity
gregory smith directed this episode
so your cousin's a shortstop no the guy
from small soldiers
oh damn director of flash too look i
don't know what you're talking about
oh he could feel his son
oh no don't don't go to school jordan
jordan hey guys
wow this is not changed
you're spying on us what
oh you got to give up that jordan kid
for adoption
his first reaction to everything is
a sour one could have said something
this morning but instead you lied to our
faces
it wasn't a lie you just didn't ask how
long have you been doing this
do you hear us masturbating those are
the times that evolved newton's had
please don't
having a new power is a lot yeah so that
was a lie too
i hope you two doesn't flag us for that
word
do you remember the first time i caught
you listening in on me
oh clark no i thought i was gonna lose
you forever
oh that was almost dead oh this is a
much more
it's probably a call back to some scene
we never saw they lighten us
any suggestions on how to make things
right with the boys make them the same
promise you made me
it's a real cold town isn't it it is
that's right
i'm sorry no more listening in on your
conversations i'll give you my word
i'm superman i'm sorry are we good
sure whatever just the paper that just
published that article about edge
intercorp
now which one of you is calling around
new carthage looking for a new story
that would be me miss powell
sharon powell miss powell i'm lois lane
does this have anything to do with
morgan edge
yeah you're damn right it does i'm
hoping you can help me nail that
bastard's
ass to the wall powell
sounds violent power powell
my son was a minor at the edge facility
in new carthage
he worked there uh six months made good
money too
he even sent someone back home well that
all changed the day morgan edge offered
him the
opportunity of a lifetime derek had to
sign a bunch of paperwork
keeping him quiet why do you think the
racell play involved
hey mom i wish i caught you this
opportunity isn't what i thought it was
foul please just one of you know that
i loved you bye that was the last time
this just became personal
[Music]
dane cook
dane cook's playing jimmy olsen is that
what's happening right now
it's about time we got back into acting
where's he been
oh damn we got a breakup story
you better learn to stay in your lane i
did see the white bully on the
under i don't remember
i think let us know yo
these are professional cheerleaders in
smallville
14 other girls are working their butts
off and you are barely paying attention
what's going on this is important what
has gotten into you lately
have this conversation right here in
front of everybody
i quit how about
what's that crazy about the show i
really care about all this stuff
like the newspaper the school [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my you shouldn't be playing man
you're gonna knock someone's head uh
yeah you shouldn't play
what are you doing i mean i kind of want
to see it happen for the team
that is a terrible idea oh jordan
you just like you better become a
villain by the next episode to
just let it happen don't worry
who wants to play some football uh are
you
on drugs what's happening here
these guys think they can push us around
well guess what push them back
you could do it in private just like
murder him
when he's alone that's true yeah you
could just follow him home
here you are all right even the coach is
addicted to him
go on take some reps of the corner i
want someone to try to tackle him
and they just bounce off
i hope they do that throws the ball
clean into the next town jordan
she's gonna push it he's gonna go way
too far smiling now bro
yo that was cool i'm down for that
that's what i'm talking about thanks
guys i wish you with my son
i love you jordan come live with me
not so fast excuse me coach you got the
big cheese running left for a little
brother and you didn't say anything to
me
you're off the team you give me five for
keeping that from me
you give me five for keeping that from
me
what who is this coach
geez who were any of these people it's
like he's like cobra kai for
football yeah like jesus i kind of heard
you and sean earlier
it was long overdue he's just everything
the biggest [ __ ] at school yeah yeah
aside from the coach
uh sarah your mom's coming in at like an
ef4 right now sarah can i talk to you
for a minute
in front of the boys whatever you want
to say you can say it right here
do you want to explain to me what
happened back there isn't it obvious i
quit the team look i'm just trying to
keep you safe
because you think i'm going to kill
myself okay this is not
the appropriate
reaction
and back off i know you're not telling
me everything that happened
coming from the most full of crap lady
in all of smallville okay sarah
no you act like our family's so awesome
when it's literally a dumpster fire
dad sleeps on the couch every night
sophie bullies all of the kids in her
classroom
small town without taking off
you know what you gotta do jordan you
gotta kill lana it's time that's the
first order
it's time for you to break back
everything okay with lana
sarah's just worried she might offer
herself one day
not saying suicide's funny i'm making
fun of the context of the situation okay
of the characters jonathan got a couple
good reps and i really think coach is
starting to take notice yeah there's
just a little more to it than that but
that's great what are you going to do
when he comes to one of the football
games
and are you going to break it to him
might have given us our big break
here's another theory that lady was half
in the bag
so red letter media for the bird did you
smell her
i looked into derek powell while you
were with his mom it turns out the guy
has a pretty checkered past
even if that's true that voicemail was
really compelling out of context
sure but he never once mentioned morgan
edge maybe it was just a drug deal gone
wrong yeah deal with facts
at least give me the chance to prove i'm
right look
but they got themselves a superman
[Music]
we got us a hulk
i hate that but you don't happen to
drive a station wagon
well done ladies and gentlemen good
delivery kudos to the comedy skills
yo give it back why'd you lie to that
i'm following his example
okay well now that you've made your
stupid point you're done playing
football right no the team needs me and
besides coach gaines may even send me a
video jordan football is my thing not
yours yeah the only reason that you're
even playing is cause you have your
little super strength or whatever
the only reason i'm playing is because
your little football buddies need to
back off
you're welcome and besides i don't have
super strength just a little stronger
than before
stop okay kid you just leveled the
fields
i'm very naturally good on football it's
like if i played football with a bunch
of little kids
there's something wrong with playing
football against children
i'm so good
i made a total fool of myself accusing
edge like that
it's an honest mistake we have been here
for a week and somebody has already
tried to blow up my car
like folks in smallville they're good
people besides it's not like it's your
first molotov cocktail
sure i want card to look into who tried
blowing up the car
ah small town shenanigans they're good
people
they're just restless sometimes they
blow up property
way too nonchalant about this whatever
decision you make
i just want you to be able to live with
it thanks for the flowers
oh he's like i never got those flowers
flowers
at least the boys are finally settling
in uh-oh
[Music]
no no jonathan sucks at
[Music]
road you football sean you're up who you
want
i want a short stack coach shortstop all
right
okay jordan you gotta mess him up before
dad shows up you got you gotta you got
like a second
you gotta rip his legs you gotta you
gotta destroy him all right gotta beat
her
with severed arms
that's not the jordan i know
all right dang coach i quit
that's done got my revenge
you deliberately disobeyed me
your powers are not something to be
taken lightly jordan yeah well i barely
have any remember
you know what everything you do is a
mistake
you get fired you bring us here this kid
you know i just wish you would go back
to not being around anymore
oh ah feel the rewriters doing some
rewrites
on some season two [ __ ]
[Laughter]
based off of what everyone's been
reacting to about jordan
tidy this up a little bit i call them
rewriters by the way
he didn't mean all that you sure all i'm
saying is
maybe figure out the reason behind
jordan's anger and address that
testosterone hmm you going somewhere
yeah
turns out miss powell's son isn't the
only worker who's gone
there's three other employees i can't
account for we're meeting a new carthage
to go over it all
you glad dad found out now you can just
go back to hanging out with sarah
listening to lp remix morrissey or
whatever
the football coach was texting him does
that happen i don't
unless malcolm was like a kid on the
team yo man i'm a board coach
smallville honestly high school is even
above my level of football understanding
so really any help you can give me
what if jordan joining the team wasn't a
mistake not sure i see your point
trust me this this feels really weird to
say but maybe jordan needs football
i mean he's been a really messed up kid
for a really long time huh and
i don't know what if joining the team is
a good thing it's also very unfair to
the other players
he's been happy for the first time in
forever yeah being in a power position
leveraging it over the puny humans
around him
there's nothing i want more than for you
guys to be happy but we have to be
careful
and him using his strength like this it
it could raise suspicion
just because his strength isn't like
mine doesn't mean it's not elevated okay
so maybe that puts him on the level of
the other kids
it so does not he threw that kid like
five feet in the playing field sighs
have to matter
what's the point of having something
special if you're not actually allowed
to be special
i i do not agree
with the situation it's so unfair it's
like being on steroids
like that doesn't make any sense
and i feel like i don't know i mean
young people are irrational sometimes
but i feel like you would have to
realize that about yourself too
i could really decimate somebody
well it's like cheating though too it's
wrong
this is the thing you can harm people
yeah it's also cheating
it was the rules the psychological
football he plays for two days and he's
like the best defense i've ever had
like come on how's that not cheating
he's starting varsity
[Laughter]
sharon
oh the dane cook guy yeah finally here
to tell some jokes
gosh i have superman shows
oh my god she went for it
so cool well this guy's got super
strength huh
no
kryptonite bones oh oh i love my camera
work here
yeah ah
oh no this guy made a kryptonite or
something
sharon sharon owie
oh it's kind of like oh wow dude
dude it's brutal but [ __ ] the camera
works really cool yeah
those like punch jitters they throw like
an anime touch
[Music]
[Laughter]
sweet oh was
awesome that was awesome
so cool oh
and he got a wedgie when that happened
you're destroying property
he's gone are you okay she's barely
breathing you need to take her to the
hospital i'll be fine
yoha you know that was like
so cool that fight was awesome
holy crap it's like it wasn't the
biggest one but it was my favorite of
all the episodes so far it was super
impactful
if you want to talk about it i'm fine i
just can't tell anymore
i have no idea if i might lose you
forever
i'm okay mom i promise we used to be so
close honey you can quit cheer and you
can keep me at arm's distance if you
want
but please i need to know why it
happened
i just felt trapped
this town by this family
it's like the only future that i saw for
myself was
a life that i didn't want
you saw yourself turning into me that's
not what i meant
no it's okay that's true i'm the most
full of crap lady in smallville
i feel lost this is such a beautiful
scene
do you know what kind of life would make
you happy i don't know
i guess i'm bigger you know yeah
me too come here
i love you so much
man so
this creepy lurking one of your
superpowers now do not
let him join come on when i was in ninth
grade
i wanted to try out for the baseball
team my dad didn't let me i realized
one of the main reasons i wanted to try
out didn't have anything to do with
baseball
was it a girl it's always a girl he's
playing football
something that you really want he's
talking about lana i think so yeah
it makes sense i wasn't sure or anything
but
these last couple of days they've
they've kind of just been incredible
and you're sure you can keep your powers
under control yes
this is a terrible idea you cannot
explain it it's just a feeling
more than a feeling i'm gonna let my
child with the severe mood swings
and spurgeon super power yeah
put trust in him that he'll handle one
last thing
so your dad did a 180 on the whole
football thing got a little help from
john
oh even jordan's number is double
has doubled her power
your dad seems like he's really
struggling you had that's a new
assistant coach
great idea all right there's there's one
scenario i guess here that keeps it
under control
i'm just sitting in the writers room
going how
how do we keep this exact complaint yeah
he's like you guys are getting along
all right all right just pretend like
you need my help with this all right all
right yeah remember really
too much
[Laughter]
lois i need to apologize to you i
accidentally
set your car on fire such an idiot
i've never had something like this fall
in my lap before stories this important
don't usually happen
in small films a lot of important
stories you're gonna be happy in
smallville from here on outreach
you're gonna have more than you can
handle stories that need to be
get missed because there aren't enough
reporters looking for them
dude clark should come work at the paper
too come on let me show you what i've
been working on
where'd you get this from the gas
station near the motel who are you and
why is a person with
powers working for morgan edge well
how's lar gonna take care of it
[Music]
kryptonian it's done i'll call it
not jennifer lawrence what did you do
well [ __ ] there are things to uncover
here
another great installment shows become
the thing where i
selectively go what's like a super cw
moment this is like
really been touted and elevated above a
traditional cw
superhero show there's really just a
superman saving people in china scene
that looked kind of cheesy
but other than that you know like some
little corny moments here or there for
the most part i'm like three episodes in
quality of everything still really on
par
very much satisfied what i find so
interesting is
the main takeaways tend to be like the
family drama stuff
usually the superhero shows what you're
doing is you're diving into
like i feel like what i should be
leading off with is the cool fight that
happened at the end how that guy got
blasted who shows up
lar i think i mean i didn't look too far
into it because i didn't want to get
spoiled but they said you know that this
role was cast a little while ago and
announced to be like the assistant to
one of the world's most powerful people
who they did not specify obviously
probably not to
spoil morgan edge's involvement in all
of this so i imagine that's probably
what we're revealing
the thing i was trying to say my biggest
takeaways are actually not these things
biggest takeaway
um is like as cool and mysterious as it
is
as much as i love that fight like i said
during the reaction that's my favorite
fight it's all the family [ __ ] man like
at the very beginning when they're all
just you know
dousing each other and paint and how
jonathan and lois are inhaling that
paint and they're
getting high and then donating starts
having a nosebleeding moment
and then superman and jordan are just
pointing and laughing going haha you
guys are
weak we are strong we will dominate
smallville with our power
father and son like that opening scene
was so
but you guys know what i'm saying like
that that whole opening scene was really
fun
i'm so on edge about jordan being in
school
because jonathan is such a good-hearted
guy he's such a good person he's like
how much [ __ ] can you put up with with
your brother that you're look
you've always been looking out for
jordan right this is jonathan character
always looking out for jordan now that
jordan has superpowers
somehow jonathan is still looking out
for him even
more more than he did before and it's
still like you know what you should
maybe be on the football team like
jonathan is the heart
of this whole story i keep talking about
this guy
and there's a reason why i'm like um oh
crap here we go here comes the jealous
tale this is it this is jonathan's
boiling point this is when he's pushed
to the
what he's going to daddy and telling him
to let jordan join the football team
this is unexpected i love that character
but i am
very much on edge i still don't kind of
agree with it in the end i don't i mean
it's still cheating to me
it's dubious i mean
i don't know i can't argue with you
about that having clark
watch over him i thought was a good
compromise for us but at the same time
i'm like yeah at some point
something's gonna go wrong and he's
going to kill somebody exploring it
though is exciting because i mean
this is a bad idea for jordan to be
there but when the scenes are happening
in the show i'm really happy to be here
watching it it's
tense it's nerve-wracking because you're
like
he goes just slightly above slightly
above that power level
he's going to destroy someone but come
on logically it's a terrible idea
it's like the fact that he played like
two days it was like the star of the
team
this is a clear indicator that it
requires no real skill set on his end he
requires
brute force hasn't earned it and now
he's going to be like
star defense player outshine his brother
who who's passionate about this
so then we're gonna get the switcheroo
i've been waiting for where jonathan
becomes super boy
i don't know it might be a cool flip
yeah i can see it potentially happening
because that's the thing it's like
i wonder if maybe that could happen
because jordan
maybe it's just our reaction to this but
jordan often reverts to that like oh
he's he's gonna snap he's gonna go bad
and then
the ark is always like well he gets
better by the end of it though and it
seems like he's making some progress so
either they want me to be thinking this
or you know maybe they could throw some
curveball away i wouldn't mind a
curveball it's like
jordan looks like he's going down the
path of getting everything he's getting
the girl he's going to be the star
football player he's getting the powers
if anyone can get pushed to the point of
a breaking point like a snapping moment
it's jonathan
yeah and it just seems like far too
optimistic and he's got to be pushing
some of this resentment down
yeah you know i mean to be brother of
the year the way he
did every scenario to like choose
the bigger outcome yeah man he's got to
have a breaking point he's
gotta and so i i could see the show
going down that path like oh my god we
thought jordan was gonna go evil but
really he's good and
jonathan's the one who's been pushed to
this no one's even trying to look out
for his emotions
not even everyone's so concerned about
jordan you're human you'll be fine and
and it's freaking
uh you know clark and and lois are not
doing
any mending on like are you okay you
know how are you i'm just
assuming you're like a superstar inside
so are you okay though i can imagine
this is rough it's like he's getting the
girl and
freaking jonathan's girlfriend's all the
way back in metropolis town you know
anyway yeah i i i'm really enjoying that
dramatic aspect side and then even
watching
like i thought that was a surprising
moment when jordan
see like the hint of good when jordan
rushes
the sarah's ex-boyfriend now and then
he's like look it was messed up for me
to kiss her but i knocked you down
so get up we good you my [ __ ] on this
team now
but i'm a compassionate owner over your
ass
that's that's a hundred percent whatever
teen drama
absolutely but i loved uh i loved that i
thought that was a surprising moment and
and i liked that idea of clark
recognizing
you know i felt really left out and
excluded and it pained me to not
be on the on the baseball team so maybe
there's a way to make this work
and maybe there's a way to kind of
reconcile what my dad didn't give me
necessarily
despite his best intent oh yeah a
hundred percent
watching clark be a dad was cool and uh
i think another thing that i'm really
i'm so sorry to touch you
there's one rule here yeah
let me just get that dirty
germs off of me he said quite racist i
always have this
food is ready to go in a moment's notice
sarah and lana
like lana lang they've really humanized
her
and it's so interesting to get a lot of
people who are big smallville fans
love this show like there's something
that feels like almost like a spiritual
sequel it's not
but it feels that way to a certain
extent small villain friday night lights
and it's just really cool to get this uh
different version of lana lang this
mature mother
who's struggling at first i was like yo
dude don't
don't have this very private
conversation in front of all the
cheerleaders right now you're a stupid
mom lana as it went and then they got to
that bedroom scene this is like such a
real
conversation this is so real as a woman
and uh my mother is sometimes coming to
my bedroom i i know what's real
uh when it comes to a mother and
daughter talking trust me i identify
no just uh it just felt that way
resonated that way
in that moment and it was a love that
they were like just both
crying with each other over the like
honestly
usually in scenes like that one person's
crying while the other person's being
open and the fact that they were just
both crying about the truth coming out
was so touching it was so beautiful
having that sense of identity and just
this layer to lana lane that i'm not
used to or lana
lana surname
lana to whomever is obsessed with morgan
etch having this different
layer to her and sarah made me really
endeared to their dynamic which i'm so
surprised back like normally [ __ ] like
this i wouldn't care about
like just get back to superman you know
and that was actually one of my favorite
parts of this whole episode and i
haven't really
been enjoying lana all that much not
that i've disliked her but i haven't
seen that standout scene for her
this is the first time i care about her
beyond the fact that she's lana
you know and and now here you know like
when she had that scene where she's with
clark and they're talking with each
other it's like oh wow you know you're
like a lot of full-on a human
being to me now yeah i think the show is
doing such a great job of elevating
everyone little by little and even the
sarah girl you know like dealing with
her
didn't establish is this doctor sees
shows often
just jumble the two um psychiatrists and
psychologists when really a psychiatrist
is the one you talk to about medication
psychologist is who you have like talk
therapy with a lot of times in shows
they kind of just throw them both into
one and there are some people who do
both yeah they're like where you could
be a psychologist and a psychiatrist but
it wasn't made clear if she was talking
with a psychiatrist for meds or a talk
therapy psychologist which usually in
small towns is like oh
there's problems in the family you know
yeah yeah but still
surrounding that yeah i i guess i would
imagine some kind of psychologist just
given the nature
but yeah i thought that was a really
wonderful scene and it was one moment
where i realized throughout the episode
like shows like this often have very
short scenes
intercut either to set up a new sort of
stakes
or to sort of wrap up little emotional
beats and i thought that was one of the
scenes in this episode that really
got a chance to breathe a lot wider than
i usually expect that just did so much
for the entire emotionality of the scene
and i thought that that
sensibility carried across the episode
there are certain moments in certain
scenes when they're more action-oriented
that things seem to
kind of clip by or try to be fast-paced
about it but i feel like they
keep bringing me back with these
surprising character scenes
and they you know that was the probably
the richest one in this episode but even
the quiet moments between
clark and lois like when they still find
time for that even though lois is like
on her whole own adventure
investigating morgan edge and going to
other towns and like this whole thing is
widening out clark's got the problems
with the boys and policing the world
yeah yeah you know and so like there is
a certain amount of chaos that sort of
holds everything
together but i thought again this
episode did a really nice job of yeah
really anchoring everything in the
character stuff and then you do get you
know your really awesome moments of
action
i'm glad that they brought it back
around with that final fight because
during the early
you know bridge sequence i was like oh i
don't know is this going to be the
moment where the show's production
values start to slip
and it doesn't seem like that's the case
at all no but that
is still a big scene in terms of
establishing a dynamic
because i liked when clark showed up at
the school you know
as he's dealing with his teenagers and
one with powers
for now that is true like he could spy
on them and he could
this this episode dealt a lot with not
taking advantage of the fact that you
have
powers using that over or against people
like that's what it seemed to deal with
right down to the fact that clark could
easily
spy or listen in on private moments
uh with his kids you know although he
did need to show up for that
that's the thing is like he needed to be
there he was about to laser the guy in
the hallway
he needed to be there i think it's just
such like it's not a black and white
situation you know if he's about to
laser a kid yeah you know
like he's like his eyes went red it's
pretty important that clark shows up
absolutely more than anyone else's
cleric who has to show up it's something
where i
feel like you need to have a bit of some
type of alarm bell
on this jordan guy that's the back and
forth concern that i have him like i
really
admire and respect this whole thing with
him really learning how to be a dad it's
one of my favorite parts of this whole
thing
this element with your kid with super
powers who has a terrible temper problem
where every other scene he's yelling and
crying at his dad for his dad being his
dad
you know like you gotta get to a point
where you're like wait
i don't think you could just completely
be private with him you know yeah so i
i uh but i get it's like a learning
lesson but yeah i mean
so far this is really it's really great
still really loved it
and uh yeah i'm excited to see what they
tell us is going on
with with attractive looking kryptonian
lady
blasting people in smallville and yeah
the lowest investigating stuff is still
like
every time it's happening i'm really
enjoying it i'm enjoying the dynamics
between her and the owner of the
smallville gazette
she'll have a name soon that will
remember i'm enjoying their dynamics and
where that's going and building up the
reputation there but yeah you know this
show it's gonna be a bunch of craziness
and start happening in smallville all of
a sudden and i hope when it
does it creates more drama for the
family like i want it i want it to go
there
where oh it's gonna you know that small
bill is gonna have more craziness than
ever i feel like people have to start
being like ever since you guys
just moved here it's been non-stop bad
and morgan edge has been trying to help
us you just make things worse
like it has to go that bad that's what
all the juicy drama is like i could feel
this build of personal life drama
met with the higher stakes you know dc
superhero
superman [ __ ] and eventually it'll
culminate into like a pretty
wild finale maybe it'll come in some
kind of begrudging alliance between
lex and cal hell oh yeah that lexington
we're still gonna deal with still he was
not anywhere in the city
he's gonna be around and i mean if
morgan edge is the out and out you know
baddie of this season anyway you never
know all right guys
what did you think of the superman and
lois episode leave your thoughts down
below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
hit that like button last but not least
deke good old deke look deek haven't
talked with you yet but i've seen you in
the comments on youtube
now you are here today got yourself a
little patron of the day shout out and
deke
skipped to you because i just love your
name fun to say
d stands for doomsday
e stands for else worlds
k stands for call l o
and e stands for
everyone gets super powers
including you screwed up his shout outs
like what's another e name
and word nigma is what e stands for
there you go
riddler you could have said elseworlds i
said elsewhere else again
is what the other e stands for you could
have said earth crisis on
infinite earths deke you get the best
shout out dee i appreciate you being
here dude
happy to have you on our patreon page
snoop around snooper's gonna snoop let's
see what you end up enjoying around here
dude we'll be talking
[Music]
big